gather you guys make popstar which is I
think one of the best comedies of the
century it's just and I think it's one
of the best things you guys have ever
done it's kind of this magnum opus this
perfect marriage of your music with your
comedy and just kind of like done
perfectly well but I think you look at
that movie and if I start thinking about
it it seems like an incredibly hard
thing to do because you are making an
album at the same time as making a movie
same time as shooting a ton of footage
because it's mockumentary format what
was that experience like for you guys
making that film I appreciate you
noticing that that's a lot of work yeah
it was a lot of work it was definitely
like the movie we wanted to make you
know we'd been talking about some
version of it for a while and then key
that at a general meeting with Jed and
that sort of an idea came up and I was
like well if you guys want to make that
I'll produce it and it was just like
[ __ ] well that we have to well to be to
be fair a year earlier Judd had curated
Vanity Fair's comedy issue where he had
like been to guest that dinner of the
entire issue and it was like Seinfeld
and Carl Reiner and Mel Brooks and Wiig
and Chris Rock and all these people and
he had called they've called us so we
could get to a page on us which was
really nice and in the blurb of that
page the description was like these guys
are funny and naughty which is a very
nice little paragraph describing us and
then it said if they ever wanted to make
a movie my office land is and it printed
the actual Judd Apatow office line the
real phone number in Vanity Fair that
anybody could call and someone would
pick up right now and go up in top
productions and it was in the magazine
called being a good producer so that had
been you know percolating in our heads
for a year I mean whoever's working the
desk in his office is like they get any
calls I bet you people thought it was a
fake number he put these the real office
line I mean someone yeah definitely
that movie is so beloved now like I know
so many people that love that movie and
you know obviously it did not do great
at the box office well we don't check
number so we this is the first we're
hearing about told it went great this
equal script and you're still waiting to
find well I think I think my joke at the
time when we were editing it was you
guys this movie is gonna make a million
dollars well it's it's interesting
because we know I mean comedy is in kind
of a weird place right now
and not a ton of them seem to be making
10 a movie or a ton of money but that
would be the marketing seemed a little
strange I don't know how much you guys
want to get into it but to me it didn't
feel like the marketing was selling what
I saw which was I want you to talk more
about it yeah yeah tell us about your
experience how would you have done it I
want to know what your experience of
seeing the marketing was first before
you get maybe a what I saw were lack of
marketing at Justin Bieber parody which
is what a bunch of people thought it was
and they were like screw that that's
stupid and then what I saw was like kind
of a semi-autobiographical only on until
not I mean obviously Connors real is an
exaggerated character but about these
friendships and these guys that you know
love making music together making art
together and the struggles they had
through getting famous and then also
there's you know Will Forte playing
bagpipes you you you uh you kind of
nailed it there I would say they the
studio and the studio was very
supportive I'm not trying to talk bad
but the marketing department really
wanted to lean into the Bieber aspect of
it and we did not at any point feel like
what we were making was a Bieber movie
it's a movie that has like 10 jokes a
minute then three out of however many
jokes you would calculate that of Lee
you know let's say there's 500 jokes in
the movie three are directly pulled from
him you could probably find way more
about other artists and but they put all
three in every piece of marketing that
there was like every even the 30-second
ad had those three jokes and they chose
the one outfit he wore that's
same that was similar the white outfit
which is that Never Say Never outfit
it's also the never seen ever paired
with never stop never stopping that made
it seem like that something you're doing
which is a very funny title and we
agreed to it but it was that's the only
piece of writing in the whole movie
that's not ours that will stuff yeah the
working title the movie for us was
Connor for real the whole time yeah we
always thought maybe that so yeah it was
not are not necessarily our preference
for it to be so beaver driven and we
really had no specific bone to pick with
beaver we were really more interested in
making something that was commenting on
the pop machine on the music machine in
general and making crazy set pieces
within that you own if anything it's
really sympathetic to the experience of
a young person being put through that
machine it's a very sweet film I think
you know even yeah decision to all the
ridiculous Joe is neither crazy yes I
mean there's definitely moments of like
for in this case Conor like is
surrounded by people who won't [ __ ]
tell them the truth you know which is
like that's like some old royalty [ __ ]
where you're like yeah people might not
like your ideas or you even and you're
not allowed to ever learn and know that
and you can't grow because of that
that's that scary
well I love that movie so much I'm glad
that people have found it but I wish you
know I wish to Kiki come with like a big
re-release on HBO Maxim some cows well
they're listening right now so in your
court guys I just read that pop star was
on HBO max and then I told Keith that he
looks it up and it turned out it was not
our pop star
it was the Aaron Carter one for anybody
interested in pop star yeah pop star
never stop never stopping yeah but it's
just so max a real one is on HBO max
right now we have the original not the
sequel that's their first one was a
reboot we rebooted alan you guys have
any desire to do a sequel to that or
revisit that or that character if
someone ever said hey yeah we'll do it
I'm speaking for myself like I feel like
for us one there's there's there's a
heartbreak involved in the films we've
made that you put a lot of energy into
them and then when they don't do
financially well sadly that feeling
metric you have for success at the time
but it's I think we're always wanting to
push ourselves to do something else
indifferent so for me personally I think
that we'd probably want to just do
something new right so how does
macGruber Series coming the joke of even
just doing it yeah it's going great